let's bring in Josh Norman of the
Washington Redskins joins us on the
program Josh how are you I'm doing okay
I'm curious did you watch the Nationals
last night well you got to throw out the
first pitch there a couple years ago
didn't you yeah are you a baseball did
you play baseball growing up I did
grandpa early I'm curious what you
thought with Jalen Ramsey go into the
rims playing that position you know you
got him and then you have big aaron
donald everything recruit see that
parent transition who do you consider
the best defensive back in football look
at everything on the scope of it all is
you guys playing well we can tweak out
you look at the whole entire landscape
of the game we shifted the paradigm
shifted because the way it is to their
caller also just about murky next out
more so than our guys that you know I'm
also curious about playing that position
now Josh where we watch these plays and
we think something is pass interference
or it's not pass interference like do
you have a good understanding of what
you can and can't do now well you know
that's the thing like understanding of
what you can cannot do because you do
the only thing and you may not get
called for it but then you do the same
thing and you get called for it in
different games so it's kind of like
it's kind of crazy because you don't
know what she
and you can't do because and the
difference in the college the
consistency of it is not really there so
it's just harder like I said earlier the
different edges go with a guy being
conserved what you can be cannot do this
kind of effective - what because the
backs can and they're allowed to do
nails because of you know the how they
are sold with the office how do you work
an official during the game how are you
working yeah my buddy so my gosh
throughout the years you know I talked
to him for the Malaysian with me they
know I went through a lot with them it's
a time I respect but they don't care if
I do something I get caught by you know
I just can't you should be like really
I call them my name I'm a number like we
really go to call back and America it's
like here there but other no man they
calling the game is you know they see
they see it sometimes they don't want to
call it they have to call it because of
what they get told so it wants to gain
you ever had an official apologize to
you yeah but they missed a call you can
see on that play yeah see how you you
know all that here there is the car with
I'm not there come and say something but
it's rare it is you never know how
frustrated human nation how frustrating
is it with this team not playing well
not being in sync
how frustrating is it when the team is
not playing well well energy from but
then you had that thing like keeps you
going
you know if that that no that drive what
Roger to keep you going through all this
stuff that you know you can't control in
marriage frustrating we're never been in
a situation like before so it kind of
like surreal to me but I also went into
there's been all times where I'm
tradition like that one a fire so we
just got a battle out we got the first
luminosity keep it going have you seen
enough from Dwayne Haskins that you know
is going to be responsible but it's just
like you're coming into holding well
it's only to calm everybody they first
come in but you know they're telling the
songs accident so you gotta continue
your inspirations and rocks and normally
okay well Joshua thanks for joining us I
know you're short on time good luck
against the Niners
coming up next game appreciate and sorry
alrighty
Thank You Josh that's a Josh Norman for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]